everyone knows the lengths to which
Marvel Studios and Avengers end game
directors Joe and Anthony Russo have
gone to prevent any spoiler if ik leaks
from flooding the internet there's the
now-standard sneaky editing of trailers
to include and exclude certain footage
and reports of the brothers Russo
crafting purposefully confusing days on
set but now we're learning another
technique the endgame team implemented
to protect the film and keep everyone in
the dark until the movie's premiere
Bruce Banner actor Mark Ruffalo recently
revealed that he shot five different
endings for Avengers end game and for a
pretty hilarious reason chatting with
enews alongside his co-stars Chris Evans
and Karen Gillan Ruffalo admitted that
he has absolutely no idea how end game
truly ends or what really happens in the
movie because he never got a complete
script I don't know what's gonna happen
I like shot five different endings I
didn't even get a whole script I don't
know why he added that the version of
the endgame script he did receive quote
had dummy scenes in it one of which
included Evans Captain America tying the
knot we can t they have to throw mark
off the scent
why flabbergasted Ruffalo asked Evans
why Marvel's brain trust would knowingly
steer him in the wrong direction you
have earned no trust you like leak like
a bodily function it turns out that the
majority of the endgame cast was given
the same treatment as Ruffalo they shot
the film with incomplete scripts another
member of the endgame crew that wasn't
entrusted with the full story
the notorious spoiler Spiller Tom
Holland who knows even less about what
goes down and end game than Ruffalo the
Hulk's star at least had mock-up scenes
to read and fake endings to film but
Holland wasn't awarded such a luxury
director Joe Russo previously explained
that the spider-man actor only had
access to his lines and nothing else for
the very same reason Ruffalo was kept
uninformed and made to shoot a bunch of
different conclusions he said at a fan
event for the film in India Tom Holland
does not get the script Tom Holland gets
his lines and that's it he doesn't even
know who he's acting opposite
we use like very vague terms to describe
to him what is happening in the scene
because he has a very difficult time
keeping his mouth shut in defensive
marvel and the Russo brothers tactics
it's true that Ruffalo hasn't exactly
been the best gatekeeper of the studio
secrets having accidentally let slip
information that was meant to be guarded
as if his life depended on it in the
past Ruffalo unintentionally
live-streamed to his Instagram followers
the first 20 minutes of audio from thor
ragnarok during the film's los angeles
world premiere back in 2017 and who can
forget the time ruffle completely
spoiled the ending of Avengers infinity
war during an interview with ABC's Good
Morning America wait till you see this
next one everybody not everybody know
that make no mistake about it
Marvel is serious about shielding
secrets now more so than ever as the
film approaches it's April 26 launch
date the studio is going to crackdown on
potential spoilers errors so remember
kids keep those lips buttons until
everyone has a chance to see endgame or
else face the wrath of fan OHS check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Avengers
endgame are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]